c'est un sujet qui refait régulièrement
surface dans l'actualité les sacs de
plastique et leur impact sur
l'environnement
toronto a tenté de les bannir sans
succès il ya quelques années et à
montréal le maire denis coderre annoncé
la tenue de consultations publiques à ce
sujet en mai parce que malgré certains
progrès on en consomme encore beaucoup
beaucoup trop diront certains
alors pour cette chronique environnement
j'accueille avec grand plaisir chantal
srivastava qui est notre collègue des
années-lumière oms en chantant allah
soit refilée alors un dossier chaud pour
les autorités il faut savoir que si on
alignait boutabout tous les sacs de
plastique qu'on utilise chaque année au
pays
l'environnementaliste david suzuki
disait il ya quelques années qu'on
aurait de quoi faire cinquante cinq fois
le tour de la terre
au total entre 9 et 15 milliards de sacs
de plastique consommés chaque année au
pays donc un pack est monumentale
indéniable quand on sait que les sacs de
plastique sont des dérivés du pétrole et
qu'il ne se décomposent pas le moindre
attrait rapidement dans la nature alors
on oublie que ça se fragmente ça fait
des microparticules de plastique qui
vont être ingérée par les poissons par
les oiseaux et sacré à la surface des
océans de véritables continent de
plastique qui dérivent des plaques de
déchets donc on en a deux dans
l'atlantique 2 dans le pacifique une
dans l'océan indien et ses plaques de
plastique sont là des micro fragments
qui vont en tourbillon au gré du vortex
donc des courants marins avec les effets
qu'on connaît alors il ya bien sûr
l'interdiction mais à part ça il ya
d'autres solutions par exemple les sacs
biodégradables
on en entend parler mais c'est pas
évident qu'ils votre qui vont se
décomposer vraiment plus vite ou mieux
que le plastique pur pour le prouver à
des chercheurs du michigan qui viennent
encore de faire une étude où ils ont
utilisé cinq additifs avec du plastique
traiter du plastique non traités ils ont
donc fait des manipulations durant trois
ans ils ont installé ses plastiques
qu'ils ont mis dans des composteurs ils
ont enfoui dans le sol et le bilan tout
ça après des analyses que ce n'est pas
nécessairement plus efficace qu'il y ait
ou pas des additifs et les sacs
compostables on commence à en voir qu'on
commence à en voir ça dépend où vous
essayez de composter ne fait pas ça dans
votre cour parce que souvent on va voir
c'est ça qui sont fait d'amis dont 2
sous de blé et où on peut voir des logos
qui confirme qu'ils sont bel et bien
compostables mais les normes en vertu
desquels on a imposé ses logos sont
faites pour contexte industriel des
composteurs dits industriels donc pas
dans votre chez vous pendant l'heure
comment on fait pour s'y retrouver dans
tout ça firent rien d'écrit soit votre
sac de plastique vous pouvez vous dire
qu'il y re slam vous le mettez au bac de
récupération
s'il est biodégradable malheureusement
vous devez mettre à la poubelle et s'il
est compostable et que vous avez la
chance de gide dans une municipalité où
on fait la cueillette des matières donc
organique les déchets de table comme on
dit les bacs bruns et qu'on attise sac
et bien c'est ça qui l'a probablement
vont pouvoir s'y sont homologués par
votre municipalité être décomposé
entièrement dans le composteur
industriel alors très intéressant on
verra ce qui arrivera de cette
consultation publique ici à montréal
parce qu'évidemment et à toute
l'industrie du plastique
on vient de le voir en californie où il
y avait une interdiction il y aura un
référendum donc c'est pas évident de
faire passer ces mesures là parce que
l'industrie évidemment veiller au grain
il faut dire qu'avec le plastique
roussillon fait des bandes parc donc
c'est pas nécessairement une matière qui
s'envole toujours pour but mais il faut
savoir qu'est ce qu'on met ou d'accord
merci beaucoup et on chante à la semaine
prochaine